nos dicen dado que h prima de menos 4 es
igual a 0 cuál es la justificación
apropiada con base en el cálculo tomando
en cuenta que h tiene un máximo relativo
en x igual a menos 4 aquí podemos ver la
gráfica de h en color azul y no tenemos
la gráfica de h prima de x pero si
tenemos la gráfica de la segunda
derivada de h en color anaranjado nos
dicen que h prima de menos 4 es igual a
0 esto quiere decir que la primera
derivada de h en x igual a menos 4 es
igual a 0
podemos verlo en la gráfica la pendiente
de la recta tangente cuando x es igual a
menos 4 es igual a 0
teniendo en cuenta esto cuál sería la
justificación con base en el cálculo
tomando en cuenta que h tiene un máximo
relativo en x igual a menos 4 la primera
opción dice que la segunda derivada en x
igual a menos 4 es negativa que nos dice
esto si la segunda derivada es negativa
quiere decir que la primera derivada
disminuye
qué es otra forma de decir que en el
punto x igual a menos 4 es cóncava hacia
abajo lo que significa que la forma
general de nuestra curva va a lucir algo
así alrededor de x igual a menos 4 si la
pendiente en x igual a menos 4 es 0 nos
dice que en efecto tenemos un máximo
relativo en ese punto si la segunda
derivada en ese punto hubiera sido
positiva entonces tendríamos una curva
cóncava hacia arriba y si nuestra
derivada fuera igual a 0 en ese punto
entonces tendríamos un mínimo relativo
esta opción es correcta la segunda
derivada es negativa cuando x es menos 4
lo que significa que tenemos una u
invertida y que el punto donde la
primera derivada es 0 indica que tenemos
un máximo relativo encontramos la
respuesta correcta vamos a descartar las
otras opciones
la segunda opción dice h incrementa
antes de x igual a menos 4 esto es
cierto lo vemos en la gráfica y
disminuye después lo que también es
cierto es una forma de darnos cuenta de
que en ese punto
tenemos un máximo relativo suponiendo
que la función es continua en x igual a
4 esto es verdadero es una justificación
de que hay un máximo relativo pero no es
una justificación con base en el cálculo
es por eso que descartamos esta opción
la siguiente opción dice la segunda
derivada de h tiene un mínimo relativo
en x igual a menos 4 esto parece
verdadero hay un mínimo relativo aquí
pero esto no justifica porque h tiene un
máximo relativo en x igual a menos 4 por
ejemplo podemos tener un mínimo relativo
en la segunda derivada pero la segunda
derivada puede ser positiva en ese punto
como lo estoy dibujando aquí seguimos
teniendo un mínimo relativo pero si es
positivo en este punto tendremos que es
cóncava hacia abajo lo que significa que
en x igual a menos 4 la función original
no tendrá un punto máximo relativo sino
que tendrá un mínimo relativo este
enunciado no es suficiente para
asegurarnos de que tenemos un máximo
relativo la segunda derivada tiene que
ser negativa en ese punto la última
opción dice las
derivada de h es cóncava hacia arriba y
al ver la gráfica parece que esto es
cierto pero esto por sí solo no
justifica que la función original sea
cóncava hacia arriba podemos usar este
mismo ejemplo que acabo de dibujar es
una segunda derivada potencial que es
cóncava hacia arriba pero es positiva en
todo este intervalo y si esto se cumple
significa que la primera derivada se
incrementa en este intervalo y esto
significa que la función original es
cóncava hacia arriba también si esto
ocurre no tendremos un máximo relativo
en la función original
en este punto descartamos esta última
opción y con esto terminamos